Florida is the epitome of mediocrity
Florida wasn't disastrously bad during
the pandemic and it certainly wasn't
very good they had a pretty high death
rate but certainly not the highest death
rate so anyway Trump now is doing this
whole thing where DeSantis proves that
he's bad because Florida was bad during
the pandemic he's done a pretty good job
with Florida you agree why do you think
you're a better choice than DeSantis
well actually if you look at the numbers
he didn't do a great job if you take a
look at the numbers he's very high on
crime very high right he's high on crime
he's smoking it daily the top uh almost
at the top uh he I think he gets good
publicity although now people are
starting because I'm putting out the
covet numbers he didn't do well on covet
he had more deaths and almost every
country in Florida I hate to say it
because Florida's my state but he had he
did not have he did not do well